[Music]
the royal family is often described as
the firm and much like any company there
are many people involved in running it
but what exactly is the firm and how is
it all run
in their unprecedented interview with
oprah winfrey megan kept referring to
the firm
it was the queen's father king george vi
who first coined the phrase to
informally refer to the royal family
after harry and megan stepped away and
prince andrew stepped down from the
family the queen is said to have
appointed the firm of eight eight senior
working royals which includes herself
her daughter ann charles and camilla
william and kate and edward and sophie
they support the queen in her duties
like making public appearances
and diplomatic trips
but the active public lives of the
royals would not be possible without all
the departments and staff behind them
[Music]
senior working royal and their partner
have their own household made up of
staff and departments
there are literally thousands of people
working away behind the scenes to make
sure that everything runs smoothly and
the senior oils certainly depend on them
so they can carry out their official
duties the households are typically
named after buildings that they run from
so charles and camilla's is clarence
house and william and kate's is
kensington palace
there is a strict hierarchy and all
kinds of departments from hr to the
privy office and within it lots of
different roles from chefs to the lord
chamberlain the queen's household is the
largest and has an overarching advisory
role to the other households so how is
it all run
[Music]
it's made up of five main departments
first the private secretary's office sir
edward young has headed this up since
2017.
as the queen's private secretary he is
the main channel of communication
between her majesty and the government
he's in charge of her official program
and on a daily basis advises her on a
whole range of matters so he is
incredibly important and other senior
royals also have private secretaries who
carry out similar responsibilities it is
with great pleasure that i welcome you
all here tonight
the private secretary also organizes raw
speeches correspondence and official
presence for the public
the privy purse and treasurer's office
includes typical departments found in a
business like hr i.t and finance the
keeper of the privy purse and
treasurer's office is sir michael
stevens
next is the master of the households
department their remit is strictly
entertainment hospitality housekeeping
and catering so includes florists and
furniture upholsterers
vice admiral sir tony johnston byrd has
been master of the household since 2013.
the lord chamberlain's office is
responsible for organising events
including ceremonial activity like
honours state funerals raw weddings
garden parties and the opening of
parliament
lieutenant colonel michael vernon
fulfills this part-time role
finally there's the royal collection
trust which runs much like a museum
they're in charge of the public openings
of the royal family's residences
clarence house and kensington palace
have smaller but still sizable royal
households and with them many more
hundreds of staff that is a lot of
salaries so how were they paid for
earlier we mentioned the sovereign grant
which is managed by the keeper of the
privy purse and treasurer's office it's
an annual payment that's calculated
every year by the treasury and in
2021 that amount was 85.9 million so
that worked out as one pound and 29
pence per person in the uk now out of
that a core grant of 51.5
million pounds was paid towards funding
the firm's travel expenses and property
refurbishment also it goes towards
covering some of the salaries for staff
within the royal household except the
royal collection trust which is funded
by ticket sales
[Music]
and all this doesn't even include police
protection which is separately funded
and comes from an elite scotland yard
squad they provide 24-hour security for
the royals and rather than being
employed by the palace they're police
officers who apply to work for the royal
family
[Music]
it's not exactly clear how many people
and in what roles work for the royal
household there isn't a comprehensive
list publicly available with the
exception of the royal collection trust
which is published annually a quick look
at the palace's vacancies though and you
can see some of the jobs that are on
offer for example a gardener at windsor
castle or an executive assistant the
master of the household at buckingham
palace so it shows that running the firm
is far from a simple business
[Applause]
you